we felt really good and we felt so safe
khloe kardashian
is standing up for her big sis it was
such a beautiful experience and i
want kim to focus on just how beautiful
it was and what she did for everybody i
mean
i don't want that to overshadow last
week kim kardashian flew her family and
close friends to a tropical getaway for
her 40th birthday
the mom of four posted pics from the
ultra exclusive event
noting that everyone there quarantined
ahead of time and they were all tested
before they were allowed to take the
trip
but of course that didn't stop some
people from slamming kim for her b-day
posts
claiming they were insensitive given the
fact that we're in the middle of a
global pandemic
kim's caption even became a meme
isn't that crazy well on thursday coco
stopped by the ellen degeneres show and
opened up about the vacay
which she said included 20 to 25 people
and she responded to those haters i
haven't heard a lot about it but i did
hear that people were
upset that we all went out of town or i
don't really know the extent of it but
this year is a frustrating year i get it
i think there's
so many frustrations going on for
everybody
but also it's her 40th and this is
something that she really wanted to do
for us it was such a nice thing
some critics expressed concern for the
staff that had to serve the group
but the 36 year old reality star said
there was nothing but love and
appreciation from everyone they
encountered
so many people said that we were their
first party or guest that they've had in
months and what it's done like for them
to be able to pay their bills or to do
stuff for their family i mean just
hearing those
yeah messages when we were there was
really we felt really good and we felt
so
safe and you know what chloe said
they're not about to let the haters get
them down
it was such a beautiful experience and i
want kim to focus on just how beautiful
it was and what she did for everybody i
mean
i don't want that to overshadow yeah
every all the greatness
exactly the good american designer also
opened up about the recent reveal that
she
suffered from kobit 19 back in march i
just found out that i do have
corona i have been
in my room it's gonna be fine
but it was really bad for a couple days
it was so incredibly scary i mean it's
still scary but especially then when the
whole world was shutting down
and i mean we didn't have really any
information or the information we had
just changed every single day
right and so it was super super scary
chloe went into greater detail about her
symptoms
explaining how severe her experience was
i was really really sick and we were
really
alarmed but everyone else tested
negative so thank goodness
she says the hardest part of it all was
staying away from her
and tristan thompson's two-year-old
daughter true
i just was quarantined in my room for
about 16 days
we had to wait until i had negative test
results for me to leave and that was the
hardest part i mean
it's i don't care how beautiful the
place you have being taken away from
your child for that long because i
couldn't be around my daughter
sure that was the most like
heart-wrenching thing
you